Một câu nói đúng được lại có xích mạnh hơn bản tự nhiên,
con trăm nhẹ và quết mặt quý trời tại trăm.
Là bạn sẽ nhận ngay một lòng nước tăng lực tóc tá.
Nhưng điều đặt đi hơn, là một lòng nước,
điều gì kè một lời nhắn nhỏ chuyện động lực tư những người tình kế qua trước đó,
có thể chỉ là và dòng nhỏ,
nhưng đủ khi một ngày dài trở nên chảy chữ hơn một chút,
và khi đã được tiếp theo năng lượng từ lại đó,
chúng ta cũng muốn lại tỏa những điều tịch tực đến những người khác.
Thầm chỉ là người mình chưa tình gặp,
có thể ta cảm biết người nhận là ai,
nhưng điều đằng thông bị của mình sẽ đoàn thành một phần tiếp xích cho người khác,
thì bạn thân cũng nhận lại đúng năng lượng tức tư lời gảm ơn âm thầm đó.
Hãy đến chạm sạch dốc gia,
để tham gia vào chú truyền năng lượng để lại tỏa giá trị tức tính mọi người nhé.